[Music]
d'artagnan is with us and he is in
kansas hey darth anion what's up hi
ramsay it's great to talk to you
you too how can we help so i'm currently
in my penultimate semester of college in
this fall
i anticipate i'll have to pay between
fifteen hundred and three thousand
dollars out of pocket
i have a nine thousand dollar card note
that uh that i want to get rid of and i
recently got rid of investments that i
had because after listening to you i
realized i shouldn't have investments
when i'm in debt
so how should i distribute this eight
thousand dollars of investments that
i've recently just acquired into my bank
account with between like
uh living paying off my car and then the
anticipated money i'll have to spend for
tuition this fall for my last semester
so you have one semester
i'm currently in my second class this
summer and then
in the fall i'll be in my last okay and
that's total of three thousand dollars
from if i heard you correctly for
tuition yes
that i have remaining that i'll have to
pay out of pocket all right how are you
eating what are you doing for rent
food and so forth uh for
for rent in the fall i'll be paying
about 350 dollars total split between my
girlfriend and i
so i'll be paying 30 350 myself and then
i spend about five 150 on
food each month because i eat beans and
rice pretty much how are you paying for
all that i have a job uh so i live in
i live in kansas city but i go to school
and then in manhattan so when i'm in
school i'll be living in
manhattan but i commute to kansas city
because i work uh 30 hour shifts
uh because i'm a caretaker so i just
work 30 hour shifts and then go back to
manhattan
what do you make at your job uh at that
job i have another job but i work pr
in there at the job that i'm speaking to
you about i would make uh
11 an hour okay
okay so so the i guess the first goal
is pay cash for finishing school
and that includes the tuition and that
includes your living expenses
now you've got two sources to do that
that's why i'm asking all these
questions you have the income
that you have coming in and you have the
eight thousand dollars right
yes and through the end of the through
the end of the summer i anticipate i'll
make another thirty five hundred dollars
between the hours i'm working at both
jobs
this summer good so we're looking at
about well what's your budget for the
fall then
you need three thousand for tuition and
how much for to finish the fall up
another five thousand
um probably somewhere around there
probably a little less because
i don't spend that much on food or
living expenses outside of rent yeah
okay so that's the 8 000 bucks
and you got 3 500 more so you got a
little bit of pad but you don't have an
extra fifteen thousand laying around
how much is your car note uh about nine
thousand dollars
what what's the note a month oh it's
about 225.
okay that's in there too yeah yeah so i
think the car's going to get paid off
after you graduate and you're going to
use the money
from the summer and the money from the
sale of the investments to make sure you
graduate
yeah okay yeah i mean you got it's going
to take you
almost all of that but i mean you may
end up with three or four thousand
dollars laying around
by the time you graduate it sounds like
you're going to i hope you do
um maybe 5 000 laying around but when
you graduate and get the full-time
regular job and you settle into
an adult process rather than a college
process
then i would reach over and start your
baby steps and actually pay off the car
right now i'm just trying to get you out
of school with debt without that what
are you
are you do you see something different
no no no i do i don't dave that's what i
was asking i knew he had nine thousand i
just want to make sure his monthly
bills wasn't straining him with this
three thousand and another five thousand
coming
so that's what i was just trying to make
sure but i don't i don't see anything
different at all the only thing i would
add is
uh you know i i would i'm a little
concerned you know what if something
happens between you and your young lady
and y'all gotta go separately and then
your housing goes up
uh but i'm i'm agreeing with you dave
yeah
you gotta it sounds like you got a eight
thousand plus thirty five hundred and
you need
somewhere around eight thousand so
you've got somewhere around a four
thousand dollar pad
give or take the way things are laid out
today just to get through
it's not a bunch of money but at least
you've got a little bit of wiggle room
without debt that's the main thing i
want to get you out
of school with no more debt exactly and
then we can go back and clean up the
car yes later yeah uh when you actually
start with the adult job and so forth
that's what we call it i guess post
college postcard there we go
that's a good question